Joe going for those Elliott banks
[ __ ] great love sending me far away
they love it an old tire DLC it just
like running
jaysus matching quest we're sucking down
a lot of rad sticking around here suck
my balls better i'm gonna has bad so I
que nada has been suit a hazmat suit
okay so if you want to suck on some tats
you better watch what tips you're
sucking on that's all i gotta say you
don't be sucking on the wrong tets here
oh so right oh so right not my game and
thank you pretty cool real slow I gotta
say am I kind of gotta build some edoran
Stan I'm kind of tired of waiting every
two seconds we're all running right why
they gave that hat where you have
increasingly what speeds fry that cuz
[ __ ] around human 10 days you gotta
watch is Teddy's you're sucking on I
cannot sin is you gotta watch it yeah
yeah yeah what is this
all right knocking on Teddy's sucking
out today AIX talking up Teddy's get
Ellen breast milk oh baby oh baby oh man
I sour their madest Rick say this batch
okay it looks like I gotta switch to my
other shotgun or is it I get in here
no I got suck my dick [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
hey Jenna [ __ ]
quick save this [ __ ] I get over there
oh yeah [ __ ]
that's it how what get a one let these
fade a little bit come on one more key
okay good and we are flying through this
day I'll say to [ __ ] and flying through
this day on-site
if i vas they were like my
marriage my fog dms is elia dips out for
Harambee